[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليالي الاختيار السهلوها بابره
العالميه
معركه بخموت تشعل الخلاف بين زينسكي وقائد
الجيش والفينتاجون يقلل من اهميه سقوط
المدينه
المعارضه التركيه تتفق رسميا على ترشيح
كمال كليجدار اوغلو للانتخابات الرئاسيه
المقبله
مع مرور شهر على الكارثه الصليب الاحمر
يحذر من انهيار منظومه المياه شمال غربي
سوريا جراء الزلزال
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
من اوكرانيا نبدا مشاهدينا تحديدا من
الجبهه الشرقيه حيث اعلنت مجموعه فاجن
الروسيه عن سيطرتها على نحو 40% من مدينه
باخموت وقال قائد قوات فاجنر ان مدينه
باخمت مطوقه من ثلاث شبهات لتضييق الخناق
على القوات الاوكرانيه لكنه حذر من ان
التاخر في وصول الذخيره لقواته قد يمنح
القوات الاوكرانيه القدره على صد الهجوم
في اشاره جديده لتقصير موسكو في دعم
مقاتليه والتسبب بتاخير السيطره على سيطره
قلل البنتاجون من اهميتها وفق للويد استون
قائلا ان قيمتها رمزيه اكثر من انها
استراتيجيه واشار الى ان سقوطها لا يعني
ان روسيا غيرت مجريات الحرب لصالحها او
حتى تراجعت اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
اذا انسحبت شركه فادينر من فان الجبهه
ستنهار باكملها فاجنر متراصه ويمكنها سحب
الجيش الاوكراني وتدميره مع عدم السماح
لهم بالتركيز على اجزاء اخرى من خط
المواجهه ايضا نحن نتقدم الى الامام ويجب
على الاخرين اتباعنا باي طريقه لحفظ ماء
الوجه ما يعني اعاده التعلم ويمكننا
القيام بذلك من المهم كسر الصوره النمطيه
المقاتلون يسالونني لماذا التاخير في
امدادات الذخيره التي تعهدت بها وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه يجب شرح ذلك في موسكو
وايضا لماذا لا يسمحون لنا بتجنيد عناصر
الجدد
[موسيقى]
مدينه باغموت كان يقطنها 70 الف نسمه قبل
اشتداد المعارك
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
5400 اوكراني فقط لا يزالون في المدينه
الجنود الاوكرانيون المتحصنون في خنادق
مؤمن
الروس يحاصرون ضخمه من ثلاث جهات باستثناء
المحور الغربي
الجنود الروسي يتحسنون بخنادق بمحيط
المدينه لتجنب القصف الاوكراني
الرئيس الاوكراني اتفقت مع القاده
العسكريين على استمرار الدفاع عن ضخمه
وزير الدفاع الامريكي ضخمت لها رمزيه لكن
سقوطها بيد روسيا لا يغير مجرى الحرب
اطول في الحرب الاوكرانيه فجرت خلافا في
اوساط القياده باكياد وفق تقارير المانيه
وفي التفاصيل نقلت صحيفه بيلد الالمانيه
المعروفه بقربها من دوائر صنع القرار في
كييف عن مصادر لم تسميها ان خلافا اندلع
بين الرئيس الاوكراني
واهم جنرالاته وهو فاليري حول معركه باخمد
بالذات والخلاف بين الرجلين اعتبرته
الصحيفه ربما يكون طموحا سياسيا على ان
يكون مرشحا جديا لرئاسه البلاد ذا لوجني
لم يكشف ابدا عن نيته القفز للامام في هرم
السلطه باوكرانيا لكن يبدو ان زيلينسكي
والبيئه المحيطه به يرونه منافسا محتملا
وفق طبعا الصحيفه الالمانيه اما الاوساط
العسكريه الاوكرانيه فاعتبرت ان القائد
العام للقوات المسلحه يعمل فقط من اجل
النصر على القوات الروسيه ويحاول حمايه
جنوده بافضل طريقه ممكنه وهذا هو الذي ادى
للمناقشات مع القياده السياسيه حول
[موسيقى]
لم تكن سبب الخلافه الداخلي في كياف بل
انها تسببت بخلاف داخل موسكو ايضا حيث قال
قائد مجموعه فاغنرال روسيه انه تم منع
ممثله من الوصول الى مقر العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه لروسيا في اوكرانيا
وكان ايضا قائد العمليه العسكريه اشتكى في
وقت سابق من نقص الذخيره محذرا من انه اذا
اجبرت فاجنر على التراجع من باخمت ستنهار
هذه الجبهه باكملها على حد قوله
وليس ببعيد عن باخره مشاهدينا نشر الجيش
الاوكراني مقاطع مصوره لاستهداف جنود روس
داخل القنادق وعدد من المواقع التي
يتحصلون فيها في دانياس بعدد من المقذوفات
يتم القاؤها من الطائرات فلنتابعها
[موسيقى]
للحديث اكثر مشاهدينا عن ما يدور على
الجبهه معنا من كييف مراسل العربيه حذيفه
عادل ومن موسكو مراسله العربيه كاتيا طعمي
سابدا معك حذيفه ما يدور في باخموت هل
فعلا هناك من منافسه داخل دوائر صنع
القرار ام انها فقط يعني تقارير كالعاده
وللمناسبه يعني انا اشعر بالبرد الذي
تشعرون به الان بهذه الوقفه امام الكاميرا
تحياتي للعيال والحمد لله على السلامه
يعني انت كنت هنا قبل ايام قليله لذلك
تشعرين بالبرد الذي نشعر به درجه الحراره
نعم انخفضت كثيرا اعود الى الحديث عن باخب
في الحقيقه
صحيفه بيلدا الالمانيه هي التي نشرت
وتحدثت حول هذا الخلاف بين زالوجني القائد
الاعلى للقوات المسلحه او القائد العام
عفوا للقوات المسلحه والقائد الاعلى
للقوات المسلحه وهو الرئيس فلاديمير
زيلينسكي طبعا الحديث طبعا الصحيفه بنت
حديثها عن
افادات كما قالت من عده مصادر سياسيه
وعسكريه تقول ان
قائد القوات المسلحه نصحها بالانسحاب من
باقي منذ عده اسابيع الامر الذي لم تتم
الاستجابه له وان الان الوضع اصبح متازم
بشكل كبير وانه ما زال ينصح بذلك ولكن
طبعا مكتب الرئيس نفى ذلك تماما ونشر على
الموقع الرسمي لمكتب حول الاجتماع الذي ضم
الرئيس فلودي
القائد العام للقوات المسلحه وقائد القوات
البريه الاكسيسيرسكي وفي هذا الاجتماع تم
الحديث حصريا عن وضع القوات في الضخمه وتم
اتخاذ القرار بالاجماع كما يقول البيان من
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه عن ان عمليه الدفاع عن
باقود تستمر وكذلك طبعا القوات الاوكرانيه
تنشر بعد الفيديوهات التي تحدثت عن عمليات
تقدم واستعاده لبعض المواقع في بعض
الجبهات في اباك الوضع بحسب القياده
العملياتيه في الشرق في باقمه نعم وهو صعب
وهنالك حصار من ثلاثه جهات ولكن الجهه
الرابعه وهي الجهه الغربيه ما زالت مفتوحه
وما زال يمكن ايصال الامدادات طبعا هنا
لابد ان اذكر ان سيرتي كان قد دفع في
اليومين الماضيين بمزيد من القوات وما زال
الراي ان يدفع بمزيد من القوات للحفاظ على
هذه الجبهه الحديث عدم اهميه باخمه
الاستراتيجيه كما تقول القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه وتتحدث القياده العسكريه في
اوكرانيا ان هذا حديث يروج له من قبل
الروس لاضعاف الروح المعنويه للقوات
المقاتله في تلك المنطقه وتسكيكها في
قيادتها وفي القرار الذي يتخذ من قبل
القياده ولكن ايضا هنالك رد من قبل القوات
وهنالك زياره كانت قبل ايام قليله لسيرتي
الى جبهه القوات
يعني ان الموضوع عن عدم الاهميه
الاستراتيجيه وليس فقط كما تحدثت عنه ايضا
اليوم التصريحات الامريكيه اتت بنفس
الاطار طبعا يعني المقصود منه سياسيا هو
العكس ولكن صبت بنفس الاطار
مرحبا اليان بالفعل الخلافه تظهر من جديد
من خلال التصريحات التي يدلي بها رئيس
مجموعه فاكتور الخاصه الذي عاد وقال اليوم
اولا ان الوضع صعب جدا في بسبب اعاده تجمع
او القوات الاوكرانيه في اربعه مناطق
شبه القوات شبه محاصره في هذه المدينه
والسبيل الوحيد كما تحدث هو فقط بزياده
تزويد القوات الخاصه بالاسلحه والذخيره
لتستطيع فك الحصاره وبالتالي السيطره بشكل
كامل على المدينه عاد ووجه ايضا اتهامات
بان القوات الخاصه لا تحصل بالوقت المناسب
على ذخيره او الحجم المناسب من الذخيره
الى القوات ولكن هذا طبعا الدفاع الروسيه
كانت قطفته مرارا كانت قد تحدثت عن ان
وزاره الدفاع تقوم بارسال جميع ما يحتاجه
القوات سواء كانت قوات الروسيه او وقت
المتطوعه من اسلحه وذخائر وكان قد توقع
ايضا وزير الدفاع الروسي منذ ايام كان وقع
على القانون
يعتمد عمليه او تنظيم عمليه ارسال الاسلحه
والعتاد الى جميع القوات المتطوعه
بالتحديد لذلك الخلافات تعود من جديد بسبب
طبعا صعوبه الوضع في منطقه بخموت وحتى
الان كما تعلمين لن تستطيع القوات الروسيه
وقوات باك بالسيطره بشكل كامل على الرغم
من محاصرتها والتقدم الاخير الذي شهدناه
طبعا في المنطقه شكرا لكما مراسلي العربيه
حذيفه
ومن موسكو كاتيا تعمي على هذه الرسائل
نبقى مشاهدينا في ملف الحرب الاوكرانيه
حيث اعلن رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني دينس
شمال عن تعيين مدير جديد لمكتب مكافحه
الفساد الاوكراني مشيرا الى ان بلاده عينت
رئيسا جديدا لمكتبها الوطني لمكافحه
الفساد تكتمل بذلك وتكمل مجموعه توصيات
الاتحاد الاوروبي السابع للانضمام للاتحاد
ما يوضح عزم اوكرانيا على المضيق قدما في
مفاوضات الانضمام للاتحاد الاوروبي هذا
العام
صداقه الصين لروسيا لا حدود لها وفق قول
بكين وتدرس هنا جديا في الوقت الراهن دعم
صديقتها في الحرب عبر ارسال المعدات
والاسلحه للقوات الروسيه وفق ما كشفته
صحيفه تيليجراف البريطانيه وهذا القرار
يمكن ان يرجح كافه الحرب لصالح روسيا كما
انه قد يمكن المصنعين الصينيين من اختبار
وتقييم اسلحتهم بشكل حاسم وواقعي لتاكيد
من فعاليتها في اي صراع مستقبلي كغزو
تايوان مثلا الصين لديها الكثير لتقدمه
لروسيا لاسيما في مجال الصواريخ والاسلحه
الموجهه رغم ان الامدادات الاساسيه مثل
قذائف المدفعيه والطائرات من دون طيار من
المرجح ايضا ان تكون على راس قائمه
الامدادات لروسيا وبعد الاطلاع مشاهدينا
على بيانات تابعه للجمارك الروسيه تم
بالفعل شحن المعدات الملاحيه وقطع غيار
المقاتلات النفاثه وتكنولوجيا التش غيرها
من المعدات العسكريه من الصين الى روسيا
تقول هنا صحيفه في المقابل على مدار سنوات
اشترت بكين منتجات روسيه الصنع
وصنعت نسخا منها خاصه بها وقد اصبحت شركات
الاسلحه والدفاع الصينيه من بين اكبر
الشركات في العالم اكثر من ذلك بدات الصين
عام 2013 دمج الذكاء الصناعي في عمليه صنع
القرار بحلول عام 2035
وشرعت ببناء وشرعت ببناء اسطول من السفن
الحربيه مع اكثر من اثنتي عشره طراد
ومدمره وحامله طائرات وتقوم بكين الان
ايضا ببناء اسطول من المقاتلات الشبحيه
شبيهه بالانواع التي يمتلكها الغرب حاليا
[موسيقى]
قال مسؤولون غربيون لصحيفه فينانشيلد
تايمز البريطانيه ان روسيا متردده في شراء
صواريخ باليسيه من ايران خشيه اقدام حلفاء
اوكرانيا على تزويد اكياف بصواريخ بعيده
المدى واكد المسؤولون للصحيفه البريطانيه
ان موسكو قد تغير موقفها بسبب النقص في
حجم ذخائرها الموجهه بدقه فضلا عن تعثر
انتاجها المحلي كما نقلت الصحيفه عن سفيره
واشنطن لدى النيتو ان الغربيون يجدون
العلاقه الروسيه الايرانيه مقلقه للغايه
وان الحلف سيواصل ارسال اشارات لايران حول
مخاطر دعمها لروسيا في الحرب مع اوكرانيا
في موسكو اعلن مكتب المدعي العام الروسيه
مع انشطه منظمه شفافيه دوليه والتي تهتم
بتطوير وسائل مكافحه الفساد غير مرغوب بها
في البلاد اضيفا ان المنظمه التي يديرها
مواطنون دول اجنبيه تتدخل بشؤون روسيا
الداخليه مما يشكل تهديدا لاسس النظام
الدستوري والامن الروسي
[موسيقى]
قال المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه ان التحدث مع صناع القرار في ايران
يعني الكثير لتسهيل عمل فرق التفتيش مشيرا
الى ان المفتشين سيقومون بعملهم بشكل يومي
وفقا للسياسات الدوليه والسياسه بشكل عام
فعندما تتحدث مع صناع القرار فهذا يعني
شيئا مهما واحتراما للنتائج الى جانب ذلك
عندما تتطلع للتصريحات ببنودها الثلاث نرى
تطورا في جميع الجوانب من بينها الصور
والامر يعني ان المفتشين سيقومون بعملهم
بشكل يومي نرى ايضا التزاما كاملا فيما
يخص الرقابه التقنيه الفريق الفني سيسافر
الى ايران قريبا جدا وسيبدا العمل اعتقد
انها فرصه جيده للجميع لكنني لا استطيع
ضمانها انها ليست وعدا بل اتفاقيه صلبه
وفي النهايه اود ان اودي عملي
ون يدعون للمظاهرات ابتداء من الخد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا في تركيا اتفقت
المعارضه اخيرا على تقديم رئيس حزب الشعب
الجمهوري كمال كليتش دار اوغلو مرشحا
للرئاسه فيما خدمت الظروف الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان الساعي لفتره رئاسيه جديده فرغم
ان الزلزال سبب صدوعا كبيرا في علاقته مع
الشارع الا ان زلزالا اخر ضرب صفوف
المعارضه وادى لصدع كبير في مائده الست
المعارضه فقد فقدت معه ضلعها الثاني حزب
الجيد ويبقى رهان بين الطرفين هو القدره
على اقناع الناخب بامكانيه انتشال تركيا
من ازمتها الاقتصاديه واعاده اعمار
المناطق المنكوبه ولكن على اسس اكثر صلبه
المزيد مع الزميله روان حمزه ولكن لابد ان
ننوه بان الاحزاب الست اتفقت على ترشيح
اوغلو
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان على ابواب
انتخابات مرتقبه في حال فوزه فيها قد
يتمدد حكمه المستمر منذ عشرين عاما لكن
هناك ملفات بمثابه حجر عثره خاصه اقتصاديا
ابرزها ارتفاع التضخم لمستوى هو الاعلى
منذ 25 عاما حيث بلغ اكثر من 85% خلال
اكتوبر الماضي حاول الرئيس التركيه الدفع
باجراءات تحفيزيه غير مسبوقه للخروج من
الازمه تتضمن دعم الطاقه ومضاعفه الحد
الادنى للاجور وزياده المعاشات التقاعديه
ومنح فرص لتقاعد اكثر من مليوني شخص
الا ان الزلزال شكل له تحديا اخر المعارضه
وبعض الاتراك يحملون حكومته مسؤوليه حجم
الكارثه بين استجابه بطيئه وملفات فساد
ففي السنوات العشرين الماضيه منحت السلطات
تسعه قرارات عفوا كان اخرها في عام 2018
لمبان تعتبر غير قانونيه بينما يرغب
الكثيرون في معرفه اين ذهبت اكثر من 38
مليار دولار تحصلت عليها الحكومه عبر
ضريبه الزلزال التي بدات تطبيقها في اعقاب
زلزال عام
1999 لكن التقديرات تشير الى ان خسائر
تركيا سترتفع بعد الزلزال فتكلفه اعاده
الاعمار ستكون باهظه الثمن وثقيله على
الاقتصاد التركي قد تصل الى 100 مليار
دولار
المعارضه التركيه كانت تراهن بثقل كارثه
زلزال على حكومه اردوغان وتنبات بان تكون
القشه التي تكلفه خساره الانتخابات لكن
استطلاعات الراي تعكس حظوظ اردوغان وتشير
لفوزه بنسبه 49.8
بعدما غادرتها لنحو يومين عادت رئيسه حزب
الجيد الى طاوله المعارضه في تركيا
وبعودتها اعاده نصاب الطاوله التي كانت
تسمى قبل انسحابها المؤقت بالطاوله
السداسيه عوده ميرال اكشن وحزبها الجيد لم
تاتي عن عبث او بعد ضغوط وانما جاءت بعد
الاستجابه لمطالبها لكن بحل وسطي يرضي كل
الاطراف ميرال اكشنر كانت قد انسحبت يوم
الجمعه الفائت من التحالف لاعتراضها على
ترشيح كمال كلتشدار اوغلو رئيس حزب الشعب
الجمهوري لمنصب رئاسه تركيا في الانتخابات
القادمه لكن سحب ترشيح زعيم حزب الشعب
الجمهوري كان مرفوضا لمعظم اعضاء الطاوله
فكان الحل وسطيا يتمثل في الموافقه رسميا
على ترشيح اوغلو مع تولي اكرم امام اوغلو
رئيس بلديه اسطنبول ومنصور يواش رئيس
بلديه انقره منصبي نائب الرئيس اذا فازت
في الانتخابات المزمنه اجراءها في الرابع
عشر من مايو القادم وهو ما اكده كليتشار
اوغلو قائلا ان بقيه رؤساء احزاب الطاوله
السداسيه سيكونون نوابا للرئيس اذا فاز هو
بالانتخابات هذا بخصوص المعارضه اما على
الجانب الاخر مشاهدينا وهو حزب العداله
والتنميه المتمثل بالرئيس الحالي رجب
اردوغان الذي يرى هو ان حزبه ويرى حزبه
وانه المرشح الوحيد الذي سيفوز في هذه
الانتخابات لبل وبنتيجه ساحقه وفقا لصحيفه
لحريات التركيه في مهاجم اردوغان المعارضه
واتهمها بالتسبب بزياده اضرار الزلزال
نتابع
الاحزاب المعارضه وزعيمها زعيم حزب الشعب
الجمهوري السيد كمال كليتشار اوغلو يقومون
بتحريض الشعب للوقوف ضدنا ووضعوا عراقيل
امام عجله النمو والتحول المدني في الماضي
والان يكررون نفس توجهاتهم
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا ساعود بعد قليل الى الملف التركي
فور ضيفنا من من اسطنبول الحديث عن
الانتخابات المزمنه عقدها وعن المعارضه
والحزب الحالي والان الى سوريا حيث يصادف
اليوم مرور شهر على وقوع الزلزال الذي ضرب
تركيا وسوريا وعلى ذكر هذا الزلزال حذر
صليب الاحمر الدولي من انهيار منظومه
المياه في شمال غربي سوريا وذلك بسبب
الاضرار التي تسببها الزلزال وسببها والذي
ضرب مناطق الشمال السوري وجنوب تركيا في
السادس من فبراير الماضي هذا وداع الصليب
الاحمر جميع اطراف النزاع الى وضع
الاعتبارات السياسيه جانبا وتسيير العمل
الانساني ليتسنى تقديم الاغاثه لمن
يحتاجون اليها بغض النظر عن الوسيله وافضل
الصليب الاحمر ان منظومه المياه في حلب
اجهز عليها بسبب الزلزال وبسبب تقادمها
وقطع الغيار لم تعد متوفره وتتعرض لضغ وط
متزايده لان السكان يعتمدون عليها لتلبيه
احتياجاتهم من المياه بعدما فقدوا منازلهم
في الزلزال وحذر صليب الاحمر من حلول
كارثه صحيه في المناطق الشماليه في سوريا
بسبب الزلزال الذي دمر بنيه الصرف الصحي
كانتشار الامراض المعديه كالكوليرا وغيرها
[موسيقى]
اعود مشاهدينا الى الملف التركي
والانتخابات التركيه المقبله وينضم الي من
اسطنبول جواد جوك المحلل السياسي استاذ
جواد سابدا من الخبر العاجل الذي اوردناه
قبل قليل وهو اتفاق الطاوله السداسيه على
مرشح باسم المعارضه ماذا يعني هذا الاتفاق
ويعني كيف سيترجم بالانتخابات المقبله
تحيه لك ولمشاهدينا الكرام
بالنتيجه بعد مفاوضات قويه وصعبه وصلوا
الى نتيجه واعلنوا قبل نصف ساعه سيد كمال
كمرشح الابرز للمعارضه التركيه بالنتيجه
سوف تكون انتخاب حمله الانتخابات في هذه
المرحله تبدا وبقوه تبدا لان الوقت قليل
بعد شهرين الانتخابات
والمعارضه اتفقوا بشكل اخر اليه والى
نائبين رئيس رئيس النيابه الرئاسه
الجمهوريه مع رئيس بلديه انقرض اسطنبول
بالنتيجه هذا الشخص كمال كلو ممكن ان يجذب
اصوات الاكراد وحزب الشعوب الديمقراطيه في
المرحله الثانيه بالنتيجه بهذا الشكل
المعروف اذا قدمت قدم حزب لا بدمقراطيه
مرشحا ثالثا بعد اردوغان وكمال اوغلو ممكن
ان ننتقل الى المرحله الثانيه ثم هناك سوف
يجذب كما الكوليسترو اصوات
حزب الشعبه الديمقراطيه سوف يفوز في
الانتخابات هذه السيناريو المشهوده في
تركيا بشكل عام نعم
السياسي البحث هناك منحه اليوم دستوري
وقانوني ما قالوا
اوغلو بان كل يعني اعضاء اطول سداسيه
سيكونون نواب للرئيس ماذا يعني ذلك يعني
هل هناك تعديل دستوري هل هناك اي شيء
بالدستور ممكن ان ينص على ذلك
طبعا هناك
زبابيه بصراحه لانه الان فوزيع المناصب
بهذا الشكل لا معنى لها فعلا بالنتيجه هم
وعدوا وعدونا بانهم سوف ينتقدون الى
النظام البرلماني وهناك سوف ينتخب رئيس
الوزراء في تركيا بعد بعد
نظام الرئاسي هنا مرى الاكشنر اعلنت سابقا
انها سوف يريد تريد ان تكون رئيسه الوزراء
في تركيا طيب اذا تنتقدون الى نظام
البرلماني القوي فتبقى يبقى مقام الرئاسه
الجمهوريه في تركيا مقام بروتوكولي سوري
وشكلي فكيف يعني تؤثرون تؤكدون على هذا
المقام ذات حريصين جدا على الوصول لمقام
الرئاسيه ضمن الم تقولوا انتم تنتقدون
برلماني وتريدون ان يكون رئيس الوزراء
القوي في تركيا ولهذا السبب
المواطنين زعلانين عن هذا الاداء وغير
الهدف الاساسي اليوم من التغيير هو
التغيير الحقيقي وليس يعني توزيع المناصب
والعوده الى ما كانت عليه الامور استاذ
جواد ايضا داخل هذه الاحزاب هناك يعني
حسابات
التوازنات الداخليه داخل الاحزاب ووجود
داخل البرلمان لاحقا وكل ما الى هناك كيف
ممكن ان تؤثر على سير العمليه الانتخابيه
الرئاسيه وهل اليوم يمكن القول بان
المعارضه موحده
ليكون هناك فرصه حقيقيه للفوز امام
اردوغان
طبعا هنا سيدتي احزاب الاربعه الاخرى
صغيره جدا يعني ممكن ان يجمعوا كلهم واحد
بالمئه من الاصوات صوت حزب الشعب الجمهوري
المعارضه الاول في تركيا وحزب الخير او
حزب الجيد على
برئاسه سيده ملال اكشنال هما
هذين الحزبين
المهمين بالنتيجه سوف يوزعون
لوزارات رئاسه البرلمان التركي ومناصب
العليا مقام مات نوابر الرئاسه الجمهوريه
وغير ذلك لكن بصراحه صار الشعب في تركيا
قطبين كتب يعني قسم من الشعب التركي حريص
جدا على بقاء اردوغان وقسم اخر يريدون ان
يتخلصوا باي شكل من الاشكال من هذه
الحكومه
سوف بين هذين القطبين اليوم هناك ايضا
معركه يعني بال خطاب السياسي بين الاحزاب
ان كان اردوغان او الاحزاب المعارضه حول
موضوع الزلزال حول موضوع الاقتصادي كل
الملفات التي تشكل اليوم هم اساسي بالنسبه
للمواطن التركي كان هناك تصريح قبل قليل
للرئيس اردوغان حول هذا الموضوع بالذات
كيف يمكن ان تستفيد المعارضه من بعض
الاخفاقات التي يعني صوبت فيها على
اردوغان
خصوصا في موضوع ملف التعاطي بعد الزلزال
طبعا المعارضه لم تكن ناجحا في السنوات
الماضيه بصراحه يعني هم الان يستفيدون من
تراجع شعبيه اردوغان بسبب غلاء الاسعار
وفشل الملف الاقتصادي والعلاقات الخارجيه
مع اشقائنا بشكل عام واخيرا قضيه الزلزال
الفشل
وتاخير في المساعدات وعدم الرضا المناطق
المنكوبه بصراحه هم لا يحتاجون ان
يستفيدون كثيرا قلنا سابقا انه لو يرشحون
شخص واحد
يتمسكون به بشكل حقيقي يعني لا ان يلعبون
لعبه السياسيه خلف الكواليس ولهذا لانه
كان فشل في الانتخابات السابقه مع محرم
انجاب غير ذلك يريدون ان يعني يتمسكون به
وان ان يتوحدون حول كما الكوليستر اوغلو
ويشارك ون بشكل حقيقي ويشتغلون لهذين
الشهرين حتى يفوزون للانتخابات لانه حقيقه
انتخابات تاريخيه لافتراق التاريخ في
تركيا بشكل عام شكرا لك استاذ جواد جوكا
المحلل السياسي حدثنا من اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
احتجاجا على استمرار الهجمات الكيماويه
على المدارس في جميع انحاء ايران دعت
مجموعه شبابيه في ايران تطلق على نفسها
شباب احياء طهران الى المشاركه في تظاهره
غدا الثلاثاء امام مبنى البرلمان الايراني
ودوائر التعليم والتربيه في العاصمه
مشددين على ان هذه الممارسات هي لشد
الانتباه عن الاحتجاجات كما دعت نقابات
المعلمين وطلاب الجامعات الى تجمع احتجاجي
على مستوى البلاد ايضا غدا الثلاثاء
للمطالبه بوضع حد للقمع البيولوجي وتهديد
حياه المواطنين المجلس التنسيقي لنقابات
المعلمين طالب ايضا بالسماح لوفد من
النشاطاء المدنيين والنقابيين والسياسيين
المستقلين الى جانب مجموعه من الاطباء
ونشطاء حقوق الانسان بدراسه موضوع التصميم
داخل المدارس والتحقيق فيه وشدد المجلس
التنسيقي لنقابات المعلمين في بيانه على
ان حجم المدارس التي تعرضت للهجوم والعدد
الكبير من التلاميذ المصابين يدل على ان
مشروع الاعمال التعسفيه لمنتسب النظام
المتشددين محل شك كبير وفي نفس السياق
ابدى العديد من المنظمات النقابيه دعمها
لدعوه المجلس التنسيقي لنقابات المعلمين
حتى الوصول الى بيئه تعليميه امنه
[موسيقى]
بدورهما يسال النظام الايراني يتخبط في
رواياته بشان حالات تسمم الطالبات بين
انكار وادانا وشجب وتهديد بالعقاب المزيد
في تقرير التعليم
روايات عده والواقعه واحده 100 طالبات
الايرانيات في المشافي والسبب هجمات
بالمواد الكيماويه هرم السلطه الايرانيه
من جانبه يستنكر ويشجب المرشد الارادي علي
خامني دور للنظام في حوادث تسمم ووصف
تصميم الايرانيات بانه جريمه لا تقتفر على
السلطات تتبع قضيه تصميم التلميذات بجديه
هذه جريمه لا تغتفر تجب معاقبه مرتكبي هذه
الجريمه بقسوه الرجل الثاني في ايران
الرئيس الايراني ينكر ويرفض الاعتراف
بوقوع حالات تسمم للطالبات ويصفها بمؤامره
من العدو تسميم الطالبات حلقه اخرى من
العدو لاثاره التوتر والتهويل داخل
المجتمع ونشر الخوف
اما السلطه القضائيه في ايران فقد اكتفت
بالتعهد بتطبيق عقوبه الاعدام على
المتسببين في تسميم الطالبات كانت الحكومه
اعلنت فتح تحقيق في اسباب التسمم الا انها
لم تعلن حتى الان توقيف اي شخص
التصريحات الايرانيه المتضاقطه بشان
التسمم رافقها تشكيك من قبل السلطات في
اسبابها وصل حد وصف حالات التسمم بالتمثيل
او انها جاءت من جماعات متشدده ترفض تعليم
الفتيات
الخبراء يقولون ان هناك فرضيتين حول تسمم
الطالبات اما ان يكون السبب شغب المراهقات
او الخوف الجماعي رغم مرور اكثر من ثلاثه
اشهر على الهجمات الكيماويه لم يتم حتى
الان تحديد المتهم بهذه الظاهره
لكنها طالت حتى اللحظه مئه الطالبات
وعشرات المدارس وسببت حالا من الذعر بين
الاهالي والطالبات
ايرانيه ايضا وفي مقابله مع راديو فارده
الام النا
طق الامريكي
قال لا شرمت ابنه جمشيد شرماد ان اعدام
والدها وشيك مشيره الى ان المانيا يمكن ان
تمنع تنفيذ الحكم والافراج عن والدها من
خلال اتخاذ الاجراءات اللازمه ويذكر ان
جمشيد سجين يحمل جنسيتين الالمانيه
والايرانيه
بالحديث عن الاعدامات والسجون بايران
كثيره هي وسائل التعذيب المروعه التي
تنتهجها اجهزه النظام الايراني بحق
المعتقلين المحتجين كالاعدام الوهميه
والصعق بالكهرباء قلع الاظافر الاغتصاب
الضرب واساليب تعذيب وحشيه تستخدم في سجون
سريه في ايران بحسب تحقيق اجرته شبكه سي
ان ان بشهاده عدد من المعتقلين كيفان صمدي
واحد من اولئك شهود يقول لسي ان ان انه ظل
طيل ثلاثه اسابيع يتعرض لصنوف من التعذيب
الوحشي في احد تلك المراكز جريمته الوحيده
كانت تنظيم مجموعه من الاطباء السريين
لاسعاف الجرحى من المتظاهرين الذين
تقمعهم القوات الامنيه الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
بالعوده مشاهدينا الى ملف انهيار شبكه
الصرف الصحي في شمال سوريا بعد يعني
الحديث عنها بعد الزلزال سينضم الينا من
دمشق المتحدث باسم اللجنه الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر في سوريا عدنان حزام استاذ عدنان
يعني هو من كان من المتوقع ان يحصل ذلك
خصوصا ان هذه الشبكه تعمل بنسبه 50% بعدما
كانت في العام 2010 تعمل بنسبه 80 الى 90%
اليوم يعني كيف يمكن تجنيب السوريين ماسات
جديده بعد كل الماسي التي تحول بهم
طبعا مرور حوالي شهر من هذه الكارثه
الانسانيه القديمه
من خلال تقنيه للوطن الحالي وكذلك استجابه
الانسانيه
راينا ان ان
المنظومه المياه خاصه منظومه الكمياتها
وكذلك
بشكل كبير لتداعيات هذا الزلزال كما
تعرفين انه قبل هذا الزلزال وكما قلت
لتكريره وكذلك في بياننا ان حوالي 50%
من هذه المنظومه كان يعمل وهذه المنظومه
كما يعرف الجميع
يستفيد منها الملايين من السوريين فجاء
تحذير اللجنه الدوليه الصليب الاحمر بان
يكون هناك استجابه عاجله في من خلال تقديم
التمويل من اجل ان يكون هناك
ترميم لتلك
المنشات خاصه ونتكلم الان عن منشات يمكن
اذا لم يتم التدخل السريع فيها فيكون هناك
تمرير لتمرير نحن نتحدث عن تمرير شبكه بنى
تحتيه عندما نقول المياه وشبكه الصرف
الصحي وما الى هناك التي تضررت بفعل هذا
الزلزال يجب ان يكون هناك تنسيق بين
المناطق منها تابعه للمعارضه منها تابع
لفصائل اخرى كيف يعني من سيدير عمليه
التنسيق لتمرير هذه الامدادات
عزيزتي عندما نتكلم عن المنظومه المنظومه
التنميه والصرف الصحي بسوريا نتكلم بشكل
عام عن الجغرافيا السوريه
ككل فعندما نتكلم نحن في اللجنه الدوليه
بالاحمر من خلال تواجهنا في معظم ما في
قطر السوري نحاول ان ننسق الاعمال وكذلك
مع هيئات المياه وكذلك مع شاركنا الهلال
الاحمر العربي السوري في تلك التدخلات من
اجل ان لا يكون هناك
نقول ماساه اخرى تضاف الى الماسي التي
يعانيها الشعب السوري خاصه ان هذه
المنظومه وخاصه البنيه التحتيه الخدمات
ليست فقط حتى على مستوى
الصحيه وكذلك التعليميه للاسف الشديد جاء
هذا الزلزال ليؤثر على هذه المنظومه نحاول
طبعا من خلال تواجدنا وكذلك تواصلنا مع
جميع الاطراف نصل الى جميع الاماكن وتقديم
الانساني
شكرا لك المتحدث باسم اللجنه دوليه لصليب
الاحمر في سوريا عدنان حزام على هذه
المداخله
نبقى في سوريا مشاهدينا حيث قالت مصادر
محليه ان اعمال ان اعمال شغب وفوضى اندلعت
في سجن علياء بمدينه القامشلي الذي يضم
عناصر من داعش وتسيطر عليه قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه والصحاله استنفار للقوات في
الاحياء القريبه من السجن هذا واضافت
المصادر ان اصواتها انطلقت من جانب
المحتجزين ثلاثه اصوات اطلاق رصاص من داخل
السجن ترافقت مع حاله استنفار لقوات قصد
واستدعاء تعزيزات من مناطق عده واغلق كل
المنافذ المؤديه الى السجن قبل ان يهدا
الوضع لاحقا
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
حكومه سوناك تتقدم بمشروعا لوضع حد لطالب
اللجوء عبر بحر الماش الى بريطانيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا طلبه منظمه
العفو الدوليه للامم المتحده بالتصدي
للانتهاكات المستمره من حركه طالبان في
افغانستان بينها فرط قيود صارمه على
النساء وتقييد حريه التعبير وقالت منظمه
العفو ان طالبان استهدفت ايضا نشطاء
مدافعين عن حقوق المراه واكاديميين ونشطاء
حقوقيين في الاشهر الماضيه واحتجزتهم بشكل
غير قانوني كما منعتهم من التواصل مع
عائلاتهم ودعت المنظمه الى انشاء اليه
تحقيق مستقله في افغانستان في اقرب وقت
ممكن
[موسيقى]
الى لبنان حيث حدد القضاء يوم الخامس عشر
من مارس الجاري موعدا للسجواب حاكم المصرف
المركزي رياض سلامه في قضايا فساد واختلاف
ووفقا لمصدر القضائي اللبناني فان القاضي
شربل ابو سمره سيحقق ايضا مع مقربين من
سلامه من بينهم شقيقه رجاء ومساعدته
ماريان حويك هذا وكان القاضي ابو سمره قد
التقى ممثلين عن ثلاث دول اوروبيه تجري
تحقيقات تتعلق بشبهات فتاه تحوم حول سلامه
حيث عين ابو سمره ثلاثه خبراء ماليين
للبحث في ملف هذه القضيه المؤلف من اربعه
صناديق
اكدت القوات المسلحه الاردنيه المضيف
التعامل بكل قوه وحزم مع اي تهديد على
الحدود وذلك بعد الاشتباكات مع مجموعه
مسلحه من الجانب السوري التي حاولت تهريب
مخدرات الى الاردن وشدد الجيش الاردني في
بيانه على مواجهه اي مساعد يرد بها تقويض
وزعزعه امن الوطن وترويع مواطنيها
[موسيقى]
ذكرت صحيفه اسرائيليه ان وزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي اتمار بن غفير امر
الشرطه بالاستمرار في تنفيذ عمليات هدم
الوحدات السكنيه
للفلسطينيين التي وصفها بغير القانونيه في
القدس الشرقيه خلال شهر رمضان وقال صحيفه
ان التحرك بن غفير ياتي على الرغم من
اتخاذ قرار بمنع هدم الابنيه غير
القانونيه بحسب القانون الاسرائيلي في
القدس الشرقيه خصوصا خلال فتره رمضان لمنع
اثاره التوتر هذا وادانا السلطه
الفلسطينيه تصريحات الوزير الاسرائيلي
التي وصفتها بانها تحرض على المزيد من
تصعيد الاوضاع في ساحه الصراع وحملت
السلطه الفلسطينيه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
برئاسه نتنياهو المسؤوليه الكامله
والمباشره عن الانتهاكات المتواصله في
القدس مؤكده ان وقت جميع الاجراءات احاديه
الجانب غير القانونيه هو المدخل للالتزام
بتفهمات العقبه ووقف التصعيد الاسرائيلي
المتواصل
بدوره قال مسؤول في وزارات الدفاع
الامريكيه ان جوله وزير الدفاع الوداد
استون الى الشرق الاوسط هدفها تاكيد
للحلفاء على الالتزام والتزام بلاده تجاه
المنطقه رغم تركيز واشنطن في الاونه
الاخيره على روسيا والصين واكد المسؤول
الامريكي ان اصل سيكون صريحا مع المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين بشان مخاوفه من العنف بالضفه
الغربيه واضاف المسؤول ان وزير الدفاع
سيتشاور مع الاسرائيليين بشان اعاده
الهدوء قبل الاعياد المقبله
على الرغم من التظاهرات الشعبيه العارمه
في اسرائيل رفضا لاقرار خطه تغيير النظام
القضائي تمضي حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو قدما
باجراء تعديلات تفاصيل الخطه مع الزميله
محاسن حضاره
خطه تغيير نظام القضائي في اسرائيل مشروع
طرحه رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو قالب
الشارع راسا على عقب ابقى الاسرائيليين في
الشوارع لاسابيع لكن ما هي خطه تغيير
النظام القضائي نتنياهو يسعى لتقليص سلطات
المحكمه العليا ومنح السياسيين سلطات اكبر
باختيار القضاه عبر اجراءات تهدف كما يقول
الى اعاده التوازن الى فروع السلطه
الحكومه تتهم قضاه المحكمه العليا بانهم
موسى يسون ويتمتعون بسلطه اعلى من تلك
التي يتمتع بها نواب الكنيسه البرلمان
وافق في قراءه اولى على بندين اساسيين في
الخطه الاول يغير عمليه تعيين القضاه
والثاني يجعل المحكمه العليا غير مؤهله
لالغاء اي تعديل للقوانين الاساسيه التي
تعد بمثابه في اسرائيل اما البندول اكثر
جدلا فيقضي بادخال بند الاستثناء الذي
يسمح للبرلمان الغاء بعض القرارات المحكمه
العليا بغالبيه بسيطه تبلغ واحدا 61 صوتا
من اصل 120 عضوا في البرلمان من جهه اخرى
معارضوا المشروع يعتبرون الخطه ترمي الى
تقويد السلطه القضائيه لصالح السلطه
السياسيه محذرين من انه يشكل تهديدا لنظام
الديمقراطي برمته كما اتهمت المعارضه
نتنياهو بالسعي الى تحقيق مصالحه الشخصيه
من خلال هذا التعديل لاسقاط تهم الفساد
التي وجهها اليه القضاء
[موسيقى]
تتجه الحكومه البريطانيه برئاسه ريشيسوناك
غدا الثلاثاء الى تقديم مشروع للتعامل مع
القوارب الصغيره التي تدخل البلاد عبر
القناه الانجليزيه قد تصل حد منع
المهاجرين غير القانونيين من اللجوء الى
بريطانيا وقد لقى المشروع انتقادات عديده
من داخل حزب المحافظين الى جانب معارضه
المزيد في هذا التقرير مع الزميله عروب
عبد الحق
رئيس الحكومه البريطانيه مصمم على وضع حد
لازمه اللاجئين غير الشرعيين في بريطانيا
حيث من المتوقع ان تصدر حكومه حزب
المحافظين مشروع قانون يوضح كيفيه التعامل
مع القوارب غير الشرعيه التي تمر عبر
القناه الانجليزيه ولكن هناك العديد من
الانتقادات التي تواجه مشروع القانون هذا
الذي يوصف بانه قاسي حتى قبل صدوره مثلا
من داخل حزب المحافظين الذين يرون بان
الشوناك ربما يغامر بمنحه وعودا كبيره دون
الالتفات الى الجانب الانساني لطالبي
اللجوء كما انهم يعتبرون ان مشروع القانون
هذا لن ينجح دون مشاركه فعاله وجديه من
فرنسا حزب المعارضين حزب العمال يرى بان
مشروع القانون هذا غير قابل للتطبيق وبانه
ربما تكتيك سياسي قبيل انتخابات مايو 2024
طبعا ازمه اللاجئين غير الشرعيين ازمه
ليست جديده على بريطانيا ولكن المعطيات
السياسيه هي التي تغيرت هناك حكومه جديده
تريد اثبات نفسها هناك اعداد كبيره من
اللاجئين الذين وصلوا الى بريطانيا خلال
الاشهر القليله الماضيه ولكن الاهم ربما
ان بريطانيا تريد ان تثبت انها قادره على
السيطره على حدودها رغم وعيوبه من لندن
عروب عبد الحق العربيه
[موسيقى]
افادت صحيفه المانيه باصدار مكتب المدعي
العام الالماني اوامر بالقبض على ثلاثه
قراصنه وتحقيق مع ثمانيه اعضاء اخرين من
مجموعه دوليه مسؤوله عن هجمات على وسائل
الاعلام الالمانيه ومستشفى الماني ومن
المشتبه بهم روسيه يبلغ من العمر 14 عاما
وبشانه عرض تسلطات الامريكيه خمسه ملايين
دولار مقابل الادلاء بمعلومات عنه
اعلنت المفوضيه الاوروبيه عن تعهد تطبيق
المراسلات والمراسلات واتساب او المراسلات
واتساب والمملوك لشركه ميتا تعهد
بالامتثال للقوانين لقوانين هيئه حمايه
المستهلك في الاتحاد الاوروبي كما تعاهد
ايضا زياده الشفافيه مع المستخدمين وعدم
نقل المعلومات المستخدمين الى اطراف ثالثه
بالاضافه الى تقديم ما يثبت ان تحديث
سياسه الخصوصيه الذي تم الكشف عنه في
يناير 2022 يتوافق مع قانون المستهلك في
الاتحاد الاوروبي
شو الاخبار التكنولوجيا ايضا مشاهدينا شهد
موقع تويتر قبل نحو ساعه من الان عطلا
كبيرا مع ابلاغ مستخدمين من كل انحاء
العالم عن عدم قدرتهم على فتح روابط مواقع
الكترونيه خارجيه وصعوبه بتحميل الصور
واوضح حساب القسم التقني للشركه في تغريده
ان بعض الميزات في تويتر قد لا تعمل كما
هو متوقع في الوقت الحالي مشيرا الى ان
ذلك يعود الى خلل غير مقصود ناجم عن تحديث
المنصه
[موسيقى]
بعد عاصفه من الجدل حول تلقي الامير هاري
دعوه لحضور مراسم تتويج الملك تشارلز اكد
المتحدث باسم
تلقيا دعوه لحضور مراسم حفله تتويج لكنهما
لم يؤكد بعدما اذا كان سيحضران حفله تتويج
وكانت اثاره الانتقادات اللاذعه للعائله
المالكه شكوكا حول دعوه الامير هاري الذي
تنحى عن واجباته الملكيه في عام 2020
لحضور حفل التتويج وما اذا كان سيحضر اذا
وجهت اليه الدعوه وكان الزوجه قد اطلقا
تصريحات مسيئه بحق الملك تشارلز والامير
ويليام شقيق هذه الاكبر وافراد اخرين من
العائله المالكه في مذكرات نشرت مؤخرا مما
القى بظلاله على الاستعدادات للحدث الذي
سيقام في مايو المقبل
[موسيقى]
ختام التاسعه مشاهدينا مع العلم
معركه باخموت تشعل الخلاف بين زيلنسكي
وقائد جيشه والبنتاغون يقلل من اهميه سقوط
المدينه
تتفق رسميا على ترشيح كمال كلجدار اوبلو
للانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله
مع مرور شهر على الكارثه الصليب الاحمر
يحذر من انهيار منظومه المياه شمال غربي
سوريا جرى الزلزال
[تصفيق]
مشاهدينا التاسع انتهت ولكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره كما كل ليله والان الى 360 مع
الزميله ميسون ميسون مساء الخير بدايه
لابد الا ان نتمنى الشفاء العاجل للزميل
طاهر وماذا لديك الليله شكرا ليال طبعا
سلامته طاهر اليوم ايضا سنتحدث عن تصريحات
جروسقف زمني ايضا سنتحدث عن موضوع
المعارضه التركيه فضلا عن موضوع ما يجري
ايضا في الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
والعديد من المواضيع ايضا هناك موضوع
اذربيجان واسرائيل وهذا التعاون العسكري
وماذا ستكون ردود فعل ايران على ذلك تفضلي